Gratitude and perspective
that's the focus
of tonight's angle now two
months after the Corona virus
entered the United States via
China.
Let's not forget where it came
from it's taken the lives
of at least 27 Americans
and infected nearly 800 now
these numbers will grow over
the next weeks and months.
And they probably don't tell
an accurate picture right now
because of our relatively small
testing sample we've already
talked about this.
We all know that businesses
and workers are already
beginning to hurt working
parents are dealing with
the disruption of school
closures I'm one of them my kids
are out for the next week
at least it admits to all
of the bad news we have to keep
our perspective there is some
good news our economy is
the best in the world why due
to the policies
and the foresight of President
Trump he understands
the importance remember this
it's very critical to remember
this at this time of preserving
strong nation states namely
our own and this solid
foundation the resilience
of our workforce,
our ability to learn lessons
quickly and these types
of situations should give us
full confidence that we're going
to weather this just fine
in the end but imagine how much
worse the situation could be
right now if we didn't have
a president who acted fast
to stop travel from key high
risk areas had we not acted
quickly that number would have
been substantially more
we're taking this unbelievably
seriously the biggest thing that
we did was stopping the inflow
of people early on and that was
weeks ahead of schedule weeks
ahead of what other people would
have done and what if what
if the wuhan virus had hit after
Hillary Clinton had won
the presidency if
her handling of Benghazi is any
guide it would have been
a nightmare and certainly her
economy would have already
stalled if saith unto her
economic policies one of his
senior economic growth we saw
under President Trump and what
about Sanders or Biden
or president same problem only
worse health care is a human
right right just a privilege
for the world and that we need
to have a Medicare for all take
on the existential threat
of climate change.
And you creating in the process
will create over 10 million good
paying jobs not $15 an hour 45
50 bucks an hour with benefits
OK if you believe that more
government control shut down oil
and gas.
And as to how they would
actually handle a Corona virus
outbreak do we really think that
move to stop travel and shut
down the southern border if you
had two would you close down
the borders no we have
a president who has propagated
xenophobic anti-immigrant
sentiment from before he was
elected what we need to do is
have the scientists take a hard
look at what we need to do now
I'll translate for you no he
would not bring in more Chinese
that's what we have to handle
this problem.
And after your tax dollars are
used to develop a vaccine
a Sanders administration would
have wanted you to cover
the costs for everyone OK
but also for everyone across
the globe when that vaccine is
developed obviously it should be
made free to every person
in this country.
And in fact every person
in the world.
Why not and never content to let
a good crisis go to waste.
The left would use this health
emergency to spend money
on stupid programs any excuse
to grow our already bloated
government we had to talk about
unemployment insurance we want
paid sick leave and emergency
unemployment insurance what they
do need is paid sick leave all
right with Democrats in charge,
we would apparently not be
leaving our houses at all
at least not to go to campaign
rallies let's be fair can't win
beat your opponent can't win
we'll order him or her to stop
holding all rallies the Trump
Pence campaign will continue
to hold rallies given the fact
that all these doctors
and medical professionals are
saying avoid large crowds
he's not really doing what
they're telling people older
people to do the fact that he is
not willing to cancel his
various rallies suggests that he
is willing to place even his
most ardent supporters at risk
yeah that's what he's doing
Jackie by the way both Sanders
and Biden canceled their own
election night rallies tonight
and supposedly it was out
of concern for public health
and safety really was this done
to save lives or save face
the great socialist dream
of the Sanders crowd was over
even before tonight let's face
it so why force yourself
to address this embarrassment
in front of the cameras this
evening and speaking
of embarrassment all Joe he just
needs to stay away from
the microphones and perhaps take
a nap beyond the partisan
bickering and fear mongering now
is the time for America to stand
united preparation not panic is
key to coping with this virus
if changes have to happen
to our response they have to be
made and they have to be made
quickly we
all know by now that many
of the CDC is early Cronos
Corona virus tests were faulty
that was no doubt very
problematic yet President Trump
acted fast he cut through
the FDA red tape soon millions
of tests will be available Even
Democrat governors who've said
some really nasty things about
Trump are now lauding his
administration's response and we
had a very long conversation
and every single thing he said
they followed through on I
believe the agencies
of the federal government are
being very diligent in helping
our state in times of crisis it
helps to have a president who
makes his own decisions who
marshals the right resources
and surrounds himself with
the most competent people
to do the job he doesn't give
in to the bureaucracy he bends
it to be more nimble he pushes
obstacles out of the way
and solves problems he has
a take charge hands on approach
to the Corona virus and every
other problem he faces
he'll work with Democrats
on a legislative package to help
working families he'll do
for our emergency response
system what he's done
for our economy make it stronger
and better day by day
and that's the angle.